Speaker 1: We have folks not only from
all over the country, but quite frankly,
from all over the world who are hoping to
chat with me today. I'm going to do my best
to speak to at least a few of them. Let's speak
next to Gabriel from Colorado. Gabriel, you're
on the air. Hi. Can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: OK, so this is not so much a question,
but I do think it is important for
people to hear that a month ago,
let's say a month and a half ago, my father,
who is, you know, a very loyal Fox News viewer,
Tucker Carlson, Dan contracted the game and
sixty one healthy, active and. Two weeks,
we passed away dead. I just thought, oh,
Speaker 1: my God, I'm so sorry to hear that,
Gabriel. That's absolutely horrifying.
Speaker 4: Yeah, thank you, so it's been
a little rough, but. And to Italy to take the
opportunity to take a lesson out of it, a story
for people to hear for. It I know it can hit close
and I could anybody else you may think your family
members may think that they are safe because
you are safe as supplements and you exercise
them. Just put them out.
Speaker 1: Wow,
is has everybody else seen it as a wake up call
if people were unvaccinated to get vaccinated?
Speaker 4: As far as I can tell, at least
within the family, for the most part,
people are understanding the severity of this.
Yeah, my mom has been positive for antibodies and
they were separated, but she's
similarly sort of perspective.
So she's not getting vaccinated, but at least
she has antibodies from a previous infection.
Speaker 1: So you so your mom is
aware that your dad died of this
and she still doesn't want to get vaccinated?
Speaker 4: Yes, actually sends me a lot of these,
like a new W4 of. These all these aren't like
underground articles about. Its expert speaks
out against whatever and want not about how
terribly dangerous the that's that. Wow. Wow.
Speaker 1: Yes. Well, Gabriel, I'm so sorry to
hear that. And if anything, I hope that somebody
will hear this and it'll be a cautionary tale
and they'll go and get themselves vaccinated.
Speaker 4: Yeah, that's my home now. OK.
Speaker 1: All right, be well, my friend.
OK, take care. Wow, I mean, like this, and that's
that's what it is, right? I mean, that's the
that's the story. That's the story
we keep hearing time and time again